لذلك
يسعدني جدًا أن ألتقي بكم يا رفاق ،
ومبروك على العرض
، يقول الكثير من الناس أن هذا
الموسم يبدو أنه الأصعب
على وجه التحديد مع وفاة
جلالة الملكة
أم كيف أثر ذلك عليك
أنا  لقد اعتدت على
البكاء عندما خرجت من
قصر باكنغهام في سيارة ، وهذا هو مدى سوء حالتي ، لقد
كان الأمر فظيعًا اعتقدت أنها ستعيش
مثل الملكة الأم حتى 101 ، كنت متأكدًا من أنها
ستحقق الشخصية التي تلعبها
نعم ، كان الأمر فظيعًا محزنًا جدًا ، نعم
امرأة أعطتنا حياتها كلها
حقًا
من تعلم
رد فعلك عليها لأن هذا جزء من
نسيج أمتنا وأنت تعلم
أننا سنعيش السبعين عامًا الماضية أينما
كنت وأنت أيضًا.  إعادة لعب دور عائلتها
وقد استثمرت
ما يقرب من عامين أو أيًا كان الأمر ، لذا
كان الأمر نوعًا ما على جميع المستويات
ولكن هل تعتقد أن وفاتها سيكون لها
تأثير على كيفية
إدراك الجمهور لهذا الموسم على وجه
الخصوص بالطبع أنا  لا أعتقد أنني أعني أنا رقيقة  ك
أم
أنت تعلم أننا في أه
فحص للأحداث الماضية التي يتذكرها الناس
الآن
أم نعم ، لكن أعتقد أن هناك
عاصفة في فنجان الشاي حيث أن
جنون الوسائط في الوقت الحالي سوف
يهدأ وأنت تعرف بمجرد هذا
تمت مشاهدة المسلسل ، إنه
فحص عادل للمشهد العاطفي لهؤلاء الأشخاص
في ذلك الوقت ، وأعتقد أن الناس
بحاجة إلى الانفتاح على قلب
متفتح وليس لديهم الكثير
من التصورات المسبقة عما يعتقدون
أنه سيكون
مثلك  أعلم أعتقد أننا جميعًا نتفق على ذلك ،
نعم تمامًا ، نعم تمامًا ، ولكن
بما أنك طرحت
النزاع الضخم والنقاش الضخم ، فهناك أيضًا الكثير
من الحديث حول الحاجة إلى وضع
إخلاء مسؤولية أه يقول أن العرض
خيالي قائم على واقع الحياة  الأحداث
وكل ذلك حيث تقف في هذا النقاش
ما هو آسف ما هو النقاش
ما هو النقاش سواء أكان
نعم أم لا
أقصد
شخصيًا أعتقد أننا الآن في الموسم
الخامس والعرض معروف جدًا
أمممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممممم  لا أعتقد أنه يحتاج إليها ولكن إذا شعر بعض
الناس أنه يجب أن يكون هناك من
أجل توضيح أن هذه
دراما تلفزيونية وليس
فيلمًا وثائقيًا ،
فأنا أعتقد شخصيًا أنني أعتقد
أنك تعرف أن الجمهور  يجري
التقليل من أهمية التطبيقات من
قبل الأشخاص الذين يعتقدون أنه لا بأس في
أن هذا ليس ضمنًا في الدراما أن
هذا ليس فيلمًا وثائقيًا وهذا
نقطة مثيرة للاهتمام التي ذكرتها
ولكن الكثير من الناس يرون
أن الأشخاص خارج المملكة المتحدة على وجه التحديد
سوف يأخذونها  كنوع من الأفلام الوثائقية
، يتحدث الناس
عنها بالفعل كما لو كانت حقائق فعلية
منطقية ، سيعرفون أننا لا
نعرف ما قيل.
من الناس
يذهلون الملايين من الأشخاص الذين يشاهدون
هذا العرض الرائع كيف نعرف أن
شخصًا ما في إسرائيل أو أمريكا أو في أي
مكان سيأخذ هذا على أنه حقيقة مطلقة
أنها كلمة رائعة تخمين أنها
كلها مزدحمة إنها تليفزيون  n عرض على
Netflix يعلم الجميع أنه
قطعة من الخيال التاريخي تم
إجراؤه بدقة وهو عمل خيالي تم إنشاؤه بواسطة المسرحيين
والمبدعين والكتاب وأنت
تعلم أن حاجتنا
كجنس بشري لتخيل المشاعر العاطفية
منظر طبيعي للناس في حياتنا
العامة وهذا موضوع شرعي أود
أن أقول إنك تعلم أن الرأس الذي
يرتدي التاج هو موضوع شرعي
للتأثير الدرامي ونعم وفي هذه المرحلة هل
نظر أي شخص إليه حقًا إنها دراما
مصنوعة بشكل جميل من الدراما  لذلك
أعتقد أنك محق أعتقد أن جمهور
الجمهور في الوقت الحالي يتم
رعايته أود أن أقول ولدينا
علاقة مع فرقنا الإبداعية
وجمهورنا ويجب أن تكون لدينا
علاقة مع الصحافة ولكن
الأشياء التي نهتم بها جميعًا  في
ومنشئو هذا البرنامج هم
جمهورنا وتلك العلاقة التي تريدها وأعتقد
أنني كنت على حد قول الأميرة آن ،
أود أن أقول إن الجميع بحاجة إلى التهدئة
وهذا شيء آخر و  هل لديك أي
نصيحة مماثلة لكن وحسنتك ،
أعني أنني أعرف كلوديا لقد
نشأت بالفعل وتحب الأميرة آن بشكل صحيح أو إذا
كنت تحبها من البداية بكل
جدية ،
فسأعتبرها رمزًا نسويًا لأنك تعرف
جيلنا الجيل الأصغر
أم تعلم أنها شخصية استثنائية ،
على عكس نوع من الحساسية الحديثة ،
فهي تضع دورها قبل شخصيتها
، فهي درس في الفهم ، فأنت
تعلم حدود
وإمكانيات وصفها
الوظيفي الذي أعتقد أنه أكثر إلهامًا و
هذا شخص لم يتزعزع أبدًا ،
فأنت تعلم أن أخلاقيات العمل الخاصة
بها استثنائية ، فإن إحساسها الشخصي
بأنك تعرف
واجبك وافتقارها للغرور
، وأعتقد أن روح الدعابة لديها أعتقد أنه
حقًا امرأة يجب أن أتخلى عنها بشكل كبير
لإنجازها ، هناك الكثير
من الملكة فيها ، أليس كذلك
نعم
نعم ، الأشياء التي أمتلكها مثل
الملكة الأم هي أسنان سيئة في الفخذ
ولكن لدي تلك الطاقة وهذا حب
الحياة وأن أكون مضطربًا  أحمر من قبل الكثير من الأشخاص
لم أحصل على ذلك بعد ، لكني أعمل على
ذلك ، نعم ، وكانت تراجع القوات
في سن 101 ، نعم مذهل للغاية ،
لذا فأنا أهدف إلى ذلك ،
نعم
، أنا آسف ولكن  جيمس
أعتقد نعم ، أعتقد أن الشيء المشترك بيني
وبين أندرو هو أننا
على نفس الارتفاع تقريبًا ، نعم
إنه في الواقع نعم والأمر أكثر
صعوبة بالنسبة لك لأن الكثير من
الناس يهاجمون الأمير
أندرو خاصةً مع إبشتاين
فضيحة وكل ذلك لذلك أنا متأكد من أنه
صعب جدًا عليك آه هل سمعت
أي نوع من النقد
ليس حقًا لا أممم أعتقد أن الناس مرة أخرى
أو الغالبية العظمى من الأشخاص الذين
يشاهدون العرض أو على دراية
بالعرض سيفهمون ذلك  أنا فعلاً
ألعب حفلة نعم وهذا هو
المكان ولكن هل من الصعب أن
تحب الجزء
لا ، إنه سهل جدًا مع المواد
التي أعطيت لي ،
وقد كتب بيتر شخصية
ممتعة لها  تلعب أعني أن هناك
تهورًا في هذا الدور هو "  أعتقد أن هناك القليل من
الإغاثة الخفيفة مع
كل شيء آخر يدور حوله ،
لذا من الممتع دائمًا اللعب
والاستمتاع كممثل أنت تعرف
نوع الفكاهة ،
هل تعتقد أنه سيكون هناك موسم
ستة
نقوم بتصويره  أنت تصورها ، حسنًا ،
نعم ، أوه ، نعم ، لم ننتهي حتى مايو
أو أبريل أو مايو على ما يرام وسيكون
الموسم الأخير لأننا
اعتقدنا أولاً أن الموسم الخامس سيكون
الموسم الأخير ، نعم قل مرة أخرى ، نعم تم
إرساله أولاً  أن الموسم الخامس
سيكون الثاني هو
بالتأكيد الموسم الأخير الذي يجب أن يكون في
الموسم السادس الأخير ، حسنًا ، لذلك
لن نحصل على الموسم السابع حيث يمكننا
بالفعل رؤية الأحفاد يكبرون وكل
ما لا أفعله  أعتقد ذلك ، أعتقد أنه عليك أن
تسأل بيتر ولكن لا توجد مسافة ، نعم ،
شكرًا يا رفاق على وقتك الجميل في
التحدث إليكم ، أتمنى لكم كل
التوفيق حقًا وهو حقًا عرض رائع
أحببتكم جميعًا بصراحة لقد كان
رائعًا  مشاهدته وآمل أن
يستمتع به الناس كما نحن  ليرة لبنانية شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا لك
أجنبي